Vodafone, Vodafone, was ist hier los? Ey, das ist so schlecht. So ein Kackladen, Mann. Das ist ein Schrott, ey.
Naja, aber wie gesagt, ich würde es keinem empfehlen, i3. Ich mag keine, also ich bin ja nicht der super Tastatur-Only-Verfechter, das gar nicht.
Ich mache hier beispielsweise meine Splits und so zum Einstellen mache ich trotzdem mit der Maus.
Mein Browser bediene ich auch mit der Maus. Aber was ich an i3 mag, ist, dass i3 halt einfach so gut wie nicht da ist.
i3 ist halt, ist halt nicht im Weg. i3 ist halt einfach, einfach so wenig wie notwendig, ja.
Wo du die Wallpaper herbekommst, die Wallpaper bekommst du bei mir auf Shithub.
Da gibt es nämlich ein extra Repo für.
White Paper Happy Desktop.
Da hast du alle, alle Wallpaper.
Credits gehen natürlich nicht an mich, sondern an ihn.
Du hast, wenn du i3 verwendest, sogar ein mehr oder weniger advancedes, nach Uhrzeit gehendes Background Change Script.
Das ist das, was ich auch verwende, der alle 10 Minuten den Hintergrund wechselt, zur Tageszeit passend, eines der Bilder auswählt.
Aber das musst du nicht verwenden, kannst du auch manuell setzen.
Neu am Lästern, wie gesagt, ich bin, ich bin Linux Mint nicht verkehrt, zumal es auch auf Debian,
basiert, basierte, glaube ich, auf Ubuntu früher.
Ich glaube mittlerweile auf Debian.
Also das habe ich nie gemacht.
Ein DSL-Router.
Ich hatte, ich hatte mal in der KVM, hatte ich ein OpenSense laufen und habe darüber Internet-Router gemacht.
Das war mir aber alles viel zu sehr Single Point of Failure, die Kiste.
Nico, danke für den Sub.
Pog.
Subscription.
Dazu kann ich nur sagen.
Sag mal, wie oft ist der Streamer heute abgekackt?
Fünfmal bestimmt, oder?
XFCE ist das einzige an Desktop-Dingern, was ich halbwegs ertrage, wenn es nicht i3 sein kann.
Aber auch XFCE ist, boah, alles eklig.
Ich hatte mal eine Suse, Suse, weiß nicht was es war, so Suse 4 gab es.
Suse, da habe ich nämlich, das war noch zu Zeiten, wo es von Suse Professional und Personal Edition gab.
Das eine waren rote CDs und das andere waren irgendwie...
blaue CDs, habe ich damals auch ausprobiert, ja, ganz, ganz lange her.
Das müsste irgendwie 2000 rum gewesen sein.
Das war mein allererster Kontakt mit Windows, äh, mit Linux damals.
Der war aber nur kurz, weil ich habe das installiert, festgestellt, mein DSL-Modem geht nicht und dann habe ich wieder Windows installiert.
Hehehe, das war alles.
So sah mein erster Linux-Kontakt aus.
Damals, damals hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass ich mal mit Linux mein Geld verdiene.
Garantiert nicht.
Ja, das ist wichtig.
Ohne, ohne ASCII-Quarium geht da nix.
Ripstream, ja.
Du hast OpenSuse, ernsthaft?
Ei, ei, ei.
Aber ich denke mir, jedem was ihm da gefällt, ja.
Also ich mache um Suse ganz großen Bogen.
Was hältst du von Dualboot Windows plus Linux?
Es ist die Frage, was du machen willst.
Also pauschal, für mich, also...
Ne, pauschal kann man es nicht beantworten.
So muss man das sagen.
Für mich ist es nix.
Ich benutze lieber Windows als Host und Linux in der VM.
Weil das, was ich in Linux mache, hat in der VM überhaupt keine Performance-Probleme.
Gut, ich muss sagen, meine VM ist auch, ähm, ordentlich ausgestattet mit 8 CPU-Cores, 24 GB RAM, also mehr als manche Nicht-VM-PCs haben.
Also, was teilweise manche Hosts nicht haben.
Aber trotzdem, für mich ist der Vorteil davon, also du siehst hier, ich hab's hier in der VM, ja, halt im Fullscreen auf dem zweiten Desktop, für mich ist der Vorteil, dass ich die beiden Systeme parallel benutzen kann und in jeweiligen Systemen das machen kann, was eben gut funktioniert.
Unter Windows kann ich streamen, kann ich meine Videos machen, wenn ich denn mal welche mache, kann ich Sachen spielen.
Ohne, dass ich mich im Vorfeld damit beschäftigen muss, okay, geht das jetzt oder geht das nicht.
Muss ich mir keine Gedanken machen.
Und unter Linux mache ich alles, was Bastelsachen angeht.
Also insofern eigentlich für mich das Beste aus beiden Welten und ich könnte mir das auch gar nicht mehr vorstellen, irgendwie anders zu arbeiten.
Wenn ich Sachen programmiere und mache, machen wir das ausschließlich unter Linux.
Und wenn ab und zu mal irgendwie was gespielt wird oder sonst, dann machen wir es unter Windows.
So, nächstes YouTube-Video.
Wenn's meiner Katz wieder besser geht.
Und dann kann ich mich auf irgendwie Sachen wieder konzentrieren.
Ja, ich finde es auch sinnvoller, eine VM zu machen, weil Dualboot nervt.
Dualboot wäre nur sinnvoll, finde ich, wenn du sagen würdest, ey, ich will eigentlich hauptsächlich unter Linux unterwegs sein,
aber für den Fall der Fälle, dass doch nochmal irgendwas ist, dann Windows.
Den Fall habe ich nicht.
Ich will ja absichtlich beide Systeme gleichermaßen.
Wenn ich auch in Linux wahrscheinlich dann mehr unterwegs bin, je nachdem, wobei, das kann man so nicht sagen, je nachdem, was ich mache.
Ich würde tatsächlich sagen, ich bin in beiden Systemen ungefähr gleich viel unterwegs.
Aber wenn du halt Sachen benutzen möchtest, wie deine Grafikkarte zum Beispiel, dann ist das in der VM nix.
Aber dann brauchst du, also wenn du beispielsweise irgendwelche Machine Learning Sachen machen willst mit GPU, Acceleration spielen willst unter Linux und so,
dann ist das natürlich in der VM nix.
Es geht bis zum gewissen Grad auch in der VM, aber Grafikkarte durchreichen ist da halt nicht an der Stelle.
Zumindest nicht mit Windows und VMware Workstation.
Oh, okay.
Dass VMware sich wirklich aufhängt, ist sehr weird.
Ja, VMware Tools kann auf jeden Fall nicht schaden.
Bist du dir sicher, dass sich VMware aufhängt und nicht dein Linux irgendwelche Schmerzen hat?
Weil das ist, das ist sehr merkwürdig.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich mache es auch lieber mit VMware.
Ja, daheim natürlich nicht.
Ich mag Gnome auch überhaupt nicht.
Und ich weiß bis heute nicht, ob es Gnome oder Genome eigentlich ausgesprochen wird.
Ich mag es aber auch nicht.
Ich finde Gnome ist zu, ist viel zu, wie soll man das nennen?
Versucht zu Apple mäßig zu sein oder, wobei das ja nicht stimmt.
Das lassen sich ja nicht mal bedienen wie Apple.
Gnome versucht, glaube ich, zu Userfreundlich.
Zu sein für absolute Kack-Noobs, die aber Gnome auf dem Desktop eh nicht verwenden würden.
Ich kann Gnome schlecht beschreiben.
Ich mag es nicht.
Ich mag aber auch KDE nicht.
Aber wenn ich die Auswahl hätte, KDE oder Gnome, würde ich wahrscheinlich KDE benutzen.
Aber ich hätte auf beides absolut keinen Bock.
Für mich, für mich kommt eigentlich aktuell nur i3 in Frage.
Und wenn es wirklich was mit Fenster sein muss, dann vielleicht noch XFCE.
Aber ich könnte mir da auch nicht vorstellen, drinnen länger zu arbeiten.
Bei i3, das Gute bei i3 ist, dass man sich nicht so viel mit i3 beschäftigt.
Das Gute bei i3 ist, dass man sich nicht so viel mit i3 beschäftigt.
Display. Kein monochromes
Dings. Es ist ein Farbdisplay drauf,
wie man hier sieht, ja.
Ja, die ESP32 haben alle
WiFi und Bluetooth. Du kannst dir
auch überlegen, ob du dich
nicht noch einen noch neueren ESP32
holst.
Weil die haben mittlerweile, glaube ich, sogar
welche mit WiFi 5.
Ich habe schon
eine ganze Weile nicht mehr geguckt,
was es da alles gibt.
So S2,
S3 und so.
Ja.
S2, den verwendet, glaube ich, keiner.
C6 ist, glaube ich,
der interessante.
Ne, S3.
Irgendeiner davon hat
neuere Bluetooth-Spezifikationen.
Genau, der hat
BLE5.
Und irgendeiner davon
konnte da nicht auch irgendeine
ZigBee von? Oder bringe ich das jetzt
durcheinander?
Ja, die D1 Minis habe ich ja auch noch
in der Ladung liegen. Die sind auch okay.
Ich persönlich mag das halt mit dem
Display. Ja, Chico geht's
nicht gut. Chico hat alle...
Wobei, heute Abend geht's hier echt schon
minimal besser, muss man
sagen. Also, Chico hat
Blutdruck, hat zu hohen Blutdruck, Nierenprobleme,
Schilddrüsenprobleme, zu
wenig rote Blutkörperchen. Also,
Chico ist echt...
Der geht's nicht gut.
Tierarzt
weiß auch nicht mehr, was wir machen sollen.
Einzige Sache, die wir jetzt haben, ist
bisschen weniger Blutdruck.
Blutdruck-Medikamente und
die kriegt jetzt so eine Paste,
das ein bisschen appetitanregend sein soll.
Mal gucken.
Mal gucken,
wie lange das gut geht.
Was benutzt du als Backup-Lösung privat?
Dankeschön für den Sub übrigens.
Tatsächlich relativ
Easy-Mode.
Flexterne Platte.
Also, auf meinem Nass.
Chat ist
natürlich auch wieder Tierarzt, wie ich sehe.
Schon. Lull, Alter.
Chat, Chat kann alles.
Chat ist Anwalt und Tierarzt in einem.
Hier hast du mal gemeint, du nutzt nur Windows.
Okay, ist das so?
Erzählst du von Dual-Boot-Windows
plus Linux?
Es ist die Frage, was du machen willst.
Also...
Also, pauschal, für mich...
Ne, pauschal kann man's nicht beantworten.
So muss man das sagen.
Für mich ist es nix.
Ich benutze lieber Windows, aber...
Erzählst du von Dual-Boot-Windows?
Ja, gut, hast du abgeschnitten an der Stelle.
Toll!
Das hat mir nicht so gut gefallen.
Das ist sehr merkwürdig, wenn sich dein Linux
ohne dass groß was drauf ist, aufhängt.
Falls du dich dran erinnerst,
ich hab das Konzept für meine Abschlussprüfung
ein bisschen mehr ausgearbeitet, bezüglich Switch-Backup.
Ja, ja, erinnere ich mich dran.
Hab jetzt mit Git und Git
ein Lokal... Man kann jetzt aus...
Das hier, die Konfigurations...
Das ist nice, aber...
Wie gesagt, du musst auch...
Du musst das der IHK so verkaufen,
dass es nicht schon fertig ist, sondern
dass du die Lösung für ein Problem
suchst und dann
zeigen, wie du zu der eigentlichen
Umsetzung dann halt kommst.
Ja? Mit Produktauswahl
und alle möglichen...
Also es bringt in der Regel fast nix,
bei Projekten unnötig Sachen
anzuflanschen, dass sie noch komplizierter
werden. Es braucht ein passendes
Projekt und fast jedes Projekt ist passend,
wenn der Titel und
der Umfang, sag mal richtig gewählt,
wenn der Titel und der Umfang, sag mal richtig gewählt,
dass da genug von dem drin ist, was die IHK sehen will.
Ja. Ja.
I3 braucht nix.
Ja, mit macOS würde ich es wahrscheinlich genauso machen.
Was sagst du eigentlich zu ArtsDelivery?
Die haben es echt verkackt bei ArtsDelivery, ne?
Die hätten sich einfach EatsDelivery nennen sollen,
aber auf die Idee sind sie nicht gekommen.
Easy.
EatsDelivery wäre viel nicer gewesen,
vom Namen her.
Die wissen, wie sich momentan alle möglichen Modellbezeichnungen
von Chips als Marken, hä?
Wie kannst du dir was als Marke eintragen lassen,
wenn du das nicht erfunden hast?
Was kannst du an Shelly Empfehlungen geben?
Ja, okay.
Es gibt eine
Sache, die bei
Shelly wirklich unterschätzt ist,
den ich auch kaum sehe, das sind die
Shelly Uni Dinger.
Die sind billig
und für klein
und für kleine
sachen super super geeignet wo man mehrere inputs braucht aber diese nicht
zum schalten von 230 volt mit relay oder sowas was an shelly die meisten leute
kennen von shelly am ehesten diese dinger das sind relays die man quasi
unter den lichtschalter machen kann also nicht wirklich so wie er das zeigt den
kann man unter die lichtschalter machen
wird champ was die da zeigen wie kann man unter den lichtschalter machen
genau und dann schaltet der lichtschalter nicht mehr direkt das
licht sondern lichtschalter schaltet den shelly der shelly schaltet den relay für
für das licht und man kann es mit wlan mit wlan verbinden und man kann das
licht halt auch schalten vom handy zum beispiel
ja den meine ich den meinte ich noch gibt's denn eigentlich lieferbar
mittlerweile tatsächlich ich bin ich bin geneigt dazu den mal auszuprobieren
sondern eigenes sick be also es wäre mega wenn es mal neues wifi gebe 5g 5g
wifi für die sps du brauchst 12- Мне spieler opens ok da ist etwas zu verletzten project dafür sind es aber nur 12 Gpi Open
fiveg wifi für die sps du brauchst zwölf GpI Open
und ok da hast du etwas und wann das project die dafür sind wir mal den eindruck haben die
project ist dafür sind die noch ein bisschen kleiner ja wo der vodafone ist
am abkacken der chat ist wie gesagt auch tierarzt
das habe ich schon mal gehört es gibt ja noch mehr es gibt auch eher clown und
und alle möglichen sachen wobei er klauen er für offside backup zu
irgendwelchen cloud anbietern ist ja die sind nice die dinger wie lange habe ich
jetzt eigentlich schon geschrieben weil meine stream anzeige ist ja voll im
arsch aber noch mal noch irgendwas auf etwas auf youtube kurz gucken dass die
gefährlichste app aller zeiten dass das klingt immer so nach drama von
simplizismus software entwickelt das disaster laut vergleich wieso wir von
dropbox weg sind mich wundert dass überhaupt noch irgendjemand bei dropbox
ist man dropbox ist
so 2017 aber dann schon schon nett gerechnet er 2015 wir sind doch kein
leute wir hatten es nicht gerade von desktop environments die desktop
environment tierlist das gucken wir jetzt noch mal schnell den typ hat man
doch das letzte mal auch schon da und ich fand seine tier ist gar nicht so
schlecht das ist kein zufall
das ist kein zufall
ja echt voll blatt ich habe gestern überhaupt nicht richtig gepeint heute
als was gestern die nacht von gestern auf heute gar nicht richtig gepeint weil ich
immer nach der katze zwischendurch geguckt habe und irgendwie nicht
richtig schlafen konnte was eiltransfährt zwischen rechnern würde ich
im leben nicht dropbox verwenden für also ist die sache je nachdem was man
machen will wenn man quasi es gleichzeitig in der cloud haben möchte
für mobile zugriff oder sagen wir so backup in anführungszeichen wobei meistens cloud sind kein
richtig gutes backup weil an einer stelle gelöscht überall weg wenn es keine historie gibt und neben
bei man es auch noch an beiden rechnern brauche es ja ist ja nicht verkehrt aber wenn ich einfach
nur dateien von einem zum anderen rechner übertragen will als einmalige aktion dann
scp rsync meinetwegen fdp der markt regelt das so das wollte ich jetzt hier angucken aber das
war mal zu machen schauen wir doch mal die linux desktop environment tierlist
gut man kann auch einfach die drei verwenden was kein richtiges desktop environment ist und
deswegen auch nicht nervt okay ich sage euch jetzt mal ich sage euch jetzt mal schon wie
meine tierlist aussehen würde unity ganz unten schrott xfce pretty good ich weiß nicht was das
ist das ist das cinnamon was das was ist jemand von euch sollte das cinnamon sein dann kommt es
auch im pretty good kde
so durchschnitt keine ahnung keine ahnung keine ahnung keine ahnung das habe ich schon mal das
ist alex de oder sowas das ist naja braucht keiner das ist pretty gut und das weiß ich
auch nicht okay dann lassen wir uns jetzt mal erzählen in resolution and other things so
let's
ich würde glauben gerne hier unten rein packen
das ist lieb in china chinesen
qualität
ja pretty good also ich finde also wirklich gut ist für mich hier von nix weil ich habe euch ja
gesagt mich nerven alle des tops desktop environment aber cinnamon ist eigentlich ganz gut
cinnamon
actually great for the new user
new user in you know a lot of people love it but i put it in a pretty good category it looks like
this on linux mint uh the mint team makes it uh clem i think is one of their lead devs and he
just amazing uh tool set probably the most polished out of all the desktop environments
the only down thing i'd say about cinnamon is uh i don't like uh it's doesn't have a whole
bunch of functions and and sometimes i find myself going i wish it was a little bit more
customizable where you find a lot of these other ones but at the end of the day it's very polished
probably the most polished and i i love it for new users that's why i usually find cinnamon
auch gut uh now next up is going to be deep end deep in deep in is that china chines linux
ich das habe ich im stream mal ausprobiert und ich muss sagen erster eindruck war gar nicht so übel
hatte
ein relativ konsistentes look and feel was vielen abgeht ja und tatsächlich auch die
deep in apps die es mitbringt ging auch über rudimentäre funktionen raus ich fand das gar
nicht so übel aber trotzdem nicht so dass ich verwenden würde is an interesting one i haven't
used it for like a whole bunch of times but i i kind of want to put it in the average to pretty
good category almost in between these it does a great job with scaling it looks beautiful
like it does a great job so i i do like it for that uh however it is more of an oddball out of
these not very many people use deep in but at the same time it is pretty gorgeous and i haven't had
any issues with it now is elementary um elementary elementary als es neu war habe ich mir gedacht oh
guck mal das könnte tatsächlich was sein für die ganzen apple fanboys die gern
mac unter linux hätten ich bin mir allerdings nicht sicher wie sich das weiterentwickelt hat
ob das noch taugt wo kaufst du dein esp wenn du schnell haben willst bei amazon
ansonsten kauft dir ein 10er pack bei ali express dann sind die sport billig
like a bad mac clone uh it's actually pantheon is the desktop environment
an elementary os i think is the only one that comes with it built in there's
probably a couple other spins that have elementary for mac users coming to linux uh if if that is a
Kann ich nachvollziehen aus seiner Sicht, ja.
Ich könnte da jetzt auch nicht wahnsinnig viel drüber sagen.
Ich habe das nie groß benutzt.
Genau sowas ähnliches habe ich mir auch gedacht.
So quasi Leute, die gerne Mac unter Linux haben wollen.
Aber wie gesagt, wie es die letzten Jahre überentwickelt hat, keine Ahnung.
Bester Clipboard Manager in Linux?
Ich habe Greenclip mit der Rufi Integration.
Du weißt ja, wie es aussieht, ne?
Hast du ja schon öfters bei mir im Stream gesehen.
Wenn ich jetzt hier irgendwas copy-paste,
ich copy-paste jetzt die Zeile, zack,
dann habe ich hier meinen Clipboard Manager.
Den kann ich auch durchsuchen.
Und scrollen und alles.
Das gefällt mir am besten.
LXDE?
Ganz ehrlich, LXDE?
Warte mal, wird LXDE überhaupt noch weiterentwickelt?
Ist es jetzt nicht LXQ?
LXQT oder so?
Zumindest ganz ehrlich,
ich verstehe die Daseinsberechtigung nicht so richtig dafür.
Ist es wirklich mehr verwendet?
Ist es deprikiert?
Ja, genau.
Ich sage es auf dem Allgemeinen.
Es ist ein leichtes Desktop-Bereich.
Es ist gut, aber nicht wirklich so sexy.
Es ist ziemlich bare-bones.
Und in demselben Bereich ist LXQT die neuere Version davon,
so zu sprechen.
Es ist ziemlich das gleiche hier.
Wie installiert man Home Assistant einfach mal auf dem Raspberry Pi?
Das fertige Image nehmen?
Ja, wenn du das da drauf laufen lassen willst,
bietet es sich wirklich an,
das fertige Home Assistant-Image zu nehmen,
weil dann kriegst du Home Assistant OS dabei.
Das heißt, du kannst über das Home Assistant UI Add-Ons installieren.
Oh ne, ey, hat wieder geleckt, oder?
Ich habe es genau gesehen, es hat wieder geleckt.
Schrott, Alter.
Was ein Schrott, Mann.
Ja, also Raspberry Pi, also ich würde Home Assistant tatsächlich den in der Image nehmen.
Da kannst du nämlich auch die ganzen Add-Ons da drüber installieren.
Das sind ja unter der Home oder Docker-Container.
Und Betriebssystem-Updates machen über das Web-UI und sowas.
Also wenn ich Home Assistant nehmen würde, dann komplette Installation auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Das Image von denen.
Und am besten auf einer SSD, weil auf einer Mikro-SSD geht das auch.
Du brauchst halt, also es geht ohne Probleme auf einer Mikro-SSD.
Du brauchst aber halt eine,
gescheite, weil die ganzen Log-Bücher und sowas, die da kamen, die das schreibt, also da schreibt der relativ, also Log-Buch heißt das in der Web-Interface im Prinzip,
schreibt Home Assistant sehr viel in der SQLite-Datenbank.
Das muss schon so eine Endurance, frag mich nicht, sonst was klasse Mikro-SSD sein.
Aber SSD ist am besten.
Great for lightweight.
I think it runs on like a hundred or two hundred megs.
in memory.
I think LXDE is a little bit lighter weight.
Moment, was war das jetzt überhaupt, was er da hingezogen hat?
Ist das LXQT?
Much of the same here.
It's great for lightweight.
I think it runs on like a hundred or two hundred megs in memory.
I think LXDE is a little bit lighter weight.
Lass uns doch mal kurz was gucken.
LXQT.
GitHub.
Ah ja.
Sieht ein bisschen durcheinander aus.
Wie gesagt, ich mag's alle nicht.
LXQT.
Not by much.
They're both very lightweight.
And great desktop environments.
Was ist das?
Ist das Twitter Desktop?
Minimal systems like Netbooks.
If you want to throw it on a potato, these are usually what you use.
And then we have Budgie.
Budgie ist das?
I put it in a pretty good category.
I was always really impressed with this.
Ich habe nie, ich habe Budgie nie verwendet.
Die haben diese komische Sidebar, die man bei Windows auch hat und schon unter Windows keiner verwendet.
Nur dass sie hier ein bisschen sinnvoller erscheint mit Sound Settings und sowas drin.
Weil ich habe es bis heute nicht verstanden.
Warum gibt es?
Ach so, ja, okay.
Mittlerweile ist das tatsächlich alles eins.
Unter Windows, unter Windows 11 war das noch nicht das.
Unter Windows 10 war das noch nicht das Gleiche.
Da hat sie diese komische...
Wobei, das ist doch gar nicht die Sidebar, oder?
Was ist diese Sidebar?
Ach, keine Ahnung, Windows Logik.
...extended period of time, but I did find like a lot of its option sets and it's just overall really, really good.
I liked it.
And then we have Gnome.
Deswegen hat man Gnome nicht gesehen.
Ganz ehrlich, ich hoffe, er puttet es dorthin.
Ich mag Gnome überhaupt gar nicht.
Gnome, some people would put it right here.
Like, some people are like Gnome fanatics.
I hate Gnome, though.
I put it in the Dog Water category.
Du musst auf die Glocke klicken.
Die habe ich doch hier.
...category, for my personal opinion.
And I do that not because of functionality.
The functionality is there with Gnome and it's probably, again, pretty polished.
The one downside to Gnome that I see, where I just can't bring it to put it in any other tier other than Dog Water,
is it just installs extensions through the browser and I hate that.
That can be exploited.
Okay, kann ich verstehen, dass er das nicht mag.
Ja, verstehe ich.
Gnome hatte eine Zeit lang nicht mal einen Fensterminimieren-Button.
Das war nicht Usability genug für die.
Actually, quite a few exploits for Gnome and using actual extensions through Firefox
or a Chromium-based browser.
And you can exploit it through there.
And, you know, a lot of times...
...hat es das immer noch nicht, kann sein.
...when you do feature updates to Gnome, the past extensions then break.
It's just not a great system. I don't like it.
Now, if you're a purist and don't need any extensions with Gnome
and you just love the layout, by all means, stick with it.
It's fine for...
Denke ich auch. Das ist ja eines der riesen Vorteile, was Linux angeht.
Es gibt halt einfach für jeden irgendwas.
Ja.
Und jeder kann auch einen eigenen Desktop machen.
Wer das denn kann.
Ich mag Gnome nicht.
For those purists out there, I just don't like the standard workflow of Gnome
and adding extensions with Gnome is ugly.
I really wish they'd change it.
This is cute fish OS.
Was?
Kenne ich auch nicht.
KDE.
Das dachte ich mir.
Ich habe fast vermutet, er packt das da oben hin, weil er ist ein ziemlicher KDE-Fan.
Es ist mein Lieblings-Desktop-Environment.
Aber ich muss sagen, ich muss es in eine gute Kategorie nehmen.
Denn es gibt Bugs.
Es gibt viel Funktionalität hier.
Es ist einfach nicht so gut wie Budgie oder Cinnamon.
Aber man...
Aber du kannst halt bei KDE alles konfigurieren.
Na, alles nicht, aber sehr customisable.
KDE-Menüs von früher waren halt das krasse Gegenteil von Gnome-Menüs.
Aber wenn du ins Gnome-Terminal damals gegangen bist, konntest du einstellen.
Hintergrundfarbe, Schriftgröße, Schrift.
Bist du in Konsole gegangen bei KDE damals, hattest du erst mal 15 Untermenüs zum Ausklappen.
Viele Optionen.
Aus Windows ist es auf jeden Fall mein Lieblings-Desktop-Environment.
Es fühlt sich mehr so an.
Man kann fast alles customisieren.
Es ist großartig.
Und ich liebe es.
Aber gleichzeitig verstehe ich, dass es ein paar Fehler hat.
Ein paar Vorgaben, die ich nicht mehr täglich veröffentliche.
Aber ich habe es schon lange gemacht.
Und ich liebe es.
Ich hatte viele Desktops mit KDE.
Ich liebe die KDE-Team noch immer.
Sie sind einfach großartig.
Nächster Punkt ist Matei.
Ich werde das in den Average-Rom setzen.
Das heißt einfach nur Mate.
Es ist etwas leichter als KDE oder Gnome.
Gnome und KDE sind relativ schwer.
Ich finde, Mate geht auch halbwegs klar.
Genau.
Mate ist nämlich Gnome 2.
Gnome 2 folgt zu Zeiten, wo man Gnome noch verwenden konnte.
Unity gibt es eigentlich gar nicht mehr.
Ubuntu verwendet jetzt auch irgendeinen Gnome-Reskin.
Das heißt, aus dem Nichts kommt Version 7 aus der Community.
Jemand hat sie gekauft und dann hat sie sie wiedergelebt.
Das ist toll.
Ich liebe es, diese alten Sachen wieder zu sehen.
Es war tatsächlich...
Okay.
Wenn Unity mit Compets funktioniert, dann bin ich dabei.
Compets ist immer noch das Allerbeste.
Leider nicht mehr supportet und macht auch viele Probleme.
Aber die Zeit mit Compets auf dem Desktop war...
Da war der Linux-Desktop.
Der L Štop da.
Falls es noch jemand kennt.
Wobbly Windows und Würfel auf dem Desktop und so was.
Fenster, die abrennen.
Unity Desktop GitHub.
Hat es auch ein GitHub-Link?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, oder?
Developed Ubuntu und ich habe es nicht sehr gern.
Ich habe Gnome besser gefällt als Gnome in der heutigen Zeit.
Aber Gnome nicht sehr gut supportet!
Das macht mich davon aus, ich sollte es klar machen.
Was auch immer.
there is some charm to it i will admit that and then xfce um man ich würde xfce wenn es unbedingt
sein muss wahrscheinlich auch hier ich würde es wahrscheinlich hier oben reinpacken aber xfce ist
auch ein ziemlich zusammengestückeltes ding also ich weiß nicht nee ist alles schrott alles schrott
i3 ist das einzige was bei mir hier oben reinkommt
ja es sieht halt aus wie 1995
bist du mal der typ ist mir mit also mit den listen die ich bisher gesehen habe ich gehe
nicht bei alle mit
aber das ich kann es bei ihm nachvollziehen und es geht in die gleiche richtung wie ich das auch
sehe ja ich würde auch nichts hier oben reinpacken ehrlich gesagt für mich für mich ist nur i3 da
oben und i3 ist ja kein wirkliches desktop environment und es sogar unfair miteinander
zu vergleichen weil wenn man zum beispiel sich mal kde anguckt steckt um ein vielfaches mehr
aufwand in kde trainer als in i3 ich meine guck mal was alles zu kde gehört versus i3
also i3 sind was weiß ich ein paar hundert oder tausend zeilen code und kde plus die ganzen projekte
sind millionen
und der grund dafür ist dass es wirklich keine desktop umgebung gibt wo ich sage das ist perfekt
das ist das ist wo ich für den rest meines leibes leben möchte es gibt alle die kommen und für mich
ist es offensichtlich dass ich hier dwm benutze was bedeutet dass ich nicht mal eine desktop umgebung benutze
mit meyer der ist mir schon mal noch mal sympathisch ich meine dvm ist jetzt vielleicht auch
bedingt was ich verwenden will aber das geht mit i3 schon auf jeden fall in die richtung ist dvm
nicht in heskel programmiert oder sowas dvm war doch irgendwie hat er doch irgendwie so eine weird
champige sache my linux as is it's just not something that i found someone dvm ist im C dann bring ich's durcheinander
and just use a window manager like this and then just launch everything with how i've been using it for the
Hotkeys and customize
and change my system around with
just the CLI. I'm
totally okay with... X-Monate, genau das
habe ich gemeint, ja.
Just pulling up a terminal
and flipping over to a new workspace
and just doing it all through
a window manager. So,
you know, maybe I put some window
managers with proper customization
in the goat category,
but there's no desktop environment that just
really does it for me these days.
And that's where I'm going to leave the Linux
desktop environment tier list.
They're all really fun to do. I encourage
you to check them all out and you can just install
you know, Vanilla Debian and then just
install any one of these. Ich finde,
das deckt sich doch
ganz gut
mit meinen Ansichten, ja.
Da merkt man auch bei dem,
dass der die Sachen schon mal ausprobiert hat
und nicht einfach nur, wie sagt man so,
sich da was aus dem Ärmel schüttelt,
Fingern saugt.
Ja.
Das habe ich jetzt
ein paar Mal auch schon gehört im Chat.
Er wieder.
Du verwendest das doch gar nicht.
Der Chainlaw erzählt das auch
immer. Niemand von euch
verwendet Herbstluft-WM, Leute.
Ich kenne niemanden, der das
benutzt. Ich weiß, dass es das gibt.
Ich weiß es nicht, ob es
das noch gibt. Anscheinend gibt es
das noch. Das wurde
erst vor zwei Monaten geupdatet.
In welcher Programmiersprache
ist das?
Öh!
Hyperland finde ich
mega interessant.
Nicestes Projekt.
Finde ich wirklich mega spannend.
Leider Wayland-only und
ja, sehr
also Hardware-affin
und es geht mir vor allem nicht.
Sonst hätte ich wahrscheinlich auch schon mal
Hyperland ein bisschen mehr benutzt.
Ja, ich meine, mit Debian
mit i3 ist ja
nichts dagegen einzuwenden.
Wobei ich ja
auf dem Desktop
für mich gibt es zwei Sachen.
Das hatte er tatsächlich auch bei sich in der Tierliste
das letzte Mal.
Es gibt zwei S-Tier-Distributionen.
Arch, Linux für Desktop, Debian für den Server.
Fertig.
Man könnte jetzt vielleicht für Business Enterprise Sachen
noch argumentieren, da was anderes reinzupacken,
aber ganz ehrlich Debian auf dem Server, Arch auf dem Desktop
und fertig.
Nvidia-Treiber sind Shit unter Linux.
Das ist das Problem.
Ich mache Linux in der VM.
Aber je nachdem, was du machen willst,
das ist vielleicht auch nicht das Richtige für dich.
Da muss man schon dabei sein,
dabei sagen.
Für mich ist es das beste Setup.
Ich habe, ich habe VM
immer auf dem zweiten Desktop im Fullscreen.
Ja, so sieht es bei mir immer aus.
Vor allem im Fullscreen, schalte ich um.
Also easy, ja, zwischen zu wechseln.
Und nachdem ich der VM auch ordentlich CPU
und ordentlich RAM und ordentlich Disk gegeben habe,
habe ich damit auch keine Performance-Probleme.
Sofern man sich im Rahmen dessen bewegt,
was man eben gut mit einer VM machen kann.
Bisschen 3D-Beschleunigung in der VM.
Also wir können zum Beispiel diesen
UNI-Heaven-Engine-Benchmark.
Wie heißt der?
UNI-Engine-Heaven.
Ihr wisst, was ich meine, oder?
Dieser TESLATION-Benchmark,
den früher mal alle verwenden haben.
Ja, den kann man beispielsweise auch in der VM laufen lassen.
Er läuft mit 300 FPS richtig gut.
Das liegt aber auch an der ordentlichen Grafik,
die ich darunter habe.
Aber insgesamt gibt es halt auch viel.
Also, man kann auch Blender starten in der VM.
Aber da fängt es halt schon an, Probleme zu machen.
Also, muss man halt gucken.
Ja, für Super Tox Card reicht es auch noch.
Also, ich glaube, ich hatte noch nie den Fall,
dass mir irgendeine Debian-Kiste bei einem Update abgekackt ist.
Noch nie.
Ich hatte bei Arch Linux selten schon mal Probleme.
Auf dem Desktop halt.
Und Arch Linux hatte auch vielmehr Bleeding Edge-Pakete.
Und ich hatte bei Arch Linux selten schon mal Probleme.
Auf dem Desktop halt.
Und Arch Linux hatte auch vielmehr Bleeding Edge-Pakete.
Aber Debian bei einem Package-Upgrade.
Ich glaube, ich kann mich nicht an einen Fall erinnern,
wo bei Debian bei einem Package-Update jemals was kaputt war.
Der Scheiß funzt einfach.
Ist Looking Glass nicht diese Geschichte mit
aus der VM
irgendwelche Sachen rüberkopieren auf den anderen Monitor oder sowas?
Ist das der Ubuntu CE?
Äh. Die Ubuntu CE.
Die Ubuntu CE.
Mit Bibel.
Moment.
Wie viele Leute spenden dafür?
Okay, nicht so viele.
Weil du mit TempleOS nichts anfangen kannst.
Mit Ubuntu CE kannst du ja wenigstens gescheit arbeiten.
Auf einem Thinclient?
Das passt doch überhaupt nicht zusammen.
Du willst doch auf einem Thinclient nichts großartig virtualisieren.
Die sind ja meistens recht schwach.
Die Chancen sind nicht nachbrüstig.
Oder meinst du das ist einfach nur ein kleiner PC?
Du meinst das ist einfach nur ein kleiner PC.
Der ordentlich Leistung hat.
Aber halt klein gebaut ist.
Dann musst du dich entscheiden,
Wo du halt hauptsächlich deinen Fokus drauflegst.
Ist es eher Virtualisierung?
Du willst dich um Container-Management
Und Netzwerkshares
Und Sachen alles selbst kümmern?
Oder willst du eher dann Proxmox?
Oder willst du eher so eine All in One Lösung,
Dann Ungrade.
im virtualisierungs bereich nicht ganz so gut ist da die box box so eine ultimative lösung für alles
gibt es nicht ja genau dafür benutze ich es auch alle meine technik bastel sachen und mein
programmiergedöns mache ich unter linux in der vm und streaming videobearbeitung und spielen mache
ich unter windows das ist für mich das beste aus beiden welten und ich kann mir das auch gar nicht
mehr anders vorstellen so als so zu arbeiten für mich wirklich die beste kombination man nimmt
einfach das beste aus beiden welten und das wurde jeweilige systeme ihre ihre stärken haben ich mag
wie es ehrlich wie es fühlt sich immer so so fremd an das kann ich schlecht beschreiben ich
meine wsl ist immer noch besser als nix wsl ist immer noch besser als batch unter windows oder so
aber
irgendwie fühlt sich wsl fremd an das ist schwer zu beschreiben hängt schon an wenn du auf seine
dateien zugreifen willst das sondern auch mntc user und so gehen muss noch der interop mit den
linien und mit den windows programm macht teilweise ein bisschen probleme also ganz
ehrlich wsl ja wenn sonst nichts geht aber irgendwie fühlt sich immer noch ein bisschen
fremd an das stimmt wohl wobei ich halt ehrlich sagen muss habe ich nicht aus
probiert beim letzten arbeitgeber wo ich gearbeitet habe war hauptsächlich
angesagt aber jetzt ist es eher google dort wo ich bin also ich habe mit es ja jetzt die
letzten das letzte dreiviertel jahr nicht mal viel gemacht ja ok dual boot wenn man performance sachen
test das verstehe ich ja das macht ja auch sinn die vm das stimmt wohl ja die ist nicht ganz so
performance wie vielleicht jetzt native wobei man sagen muss mit meinem i3 setup hier den 8 cpu kern
Man merkt den Unterschied nur gar nicht, also man merkt ihn, das will ich jetzt gar nicht, will ich jetzt gar nicht bestreiten, aber es ist schon echt nicht ein großer Unterschied zu Native.
Hast du eine externe Soundkarte? Ja, habe ich. Ein Motu Track 16, das habe ich Jahre schon. Was für ein Dick. Ne, Entra heißt doch nur Azure, AD heißt Entra, oder?
Azure heißt immer noch Azure, oder habe ich das falsch verstanden? Kostet vor allem ja eigentlich was, vor allem bei Workstation kostet was, ja, aber du findest sehr günstig Keys bei Keysellern oder woanders.
Ich habe das damals auch gekauft bei einem Keyseller, für 8,50 oder sowas. Korrekt, ja, ja, ja, das ist richtig.
Ich persönlich mag...
Ich finde VMWare einfach lieber als VirtualBox. VirtualBox würde es unter Windows auch tun. Ich kann jetzt gar nicht so sagen, so nach dem Motto, VirtualBox funktioniert überhaupt nicht, deswegen nehmt VMWare, ne, das nicht.
Aber gerade wenn es darum geht, vielleicht ein bisschen 2D, 3D Acceleration zu bekommen in der VM, dann sind die VMWare Treiber doch schon eine ganze Ecke besser.
Hyper-V?
Kannst klicken dafür.
Ja, Snapshots sind dann eine der coolsten Sachen an der VM.
Ja, aber der Player zum angucken reicht auf jeden Fall, aber man kann sich für ein Appel und ein Ei beim Key-Shop VMWare Key kaufen.
Oder ich glaube, man kann sogar 30 Tage Trial machen bei VMWare, wenn ich nicht falsch liege.
Hyper-V ist ja auch nichts für Desktop-Virtualisierung.
Okay, Leute.
Spontaner Stream mit 3x Vodafone-Kacke zwischendrin.
Ich bin übelst kaputt, ich geh jetzt pennen.
Ja.
Key for Vmware Workstation, genau.
Hab ich mir irgendwie für 8,50 gekauft.
Bettge, Boomer, müde, korrekt.
Boomer, müde, Boomer, Bettge.
Wo hab ich mein Bettge-Emote eigentlich, Leute?
Hier.
Vmware Workstation kostet was, ja.
Ja, ich weiß, ich weiß.
Deswegen hab ich mir auch bei dem Key-Shop was gekauft für 8,50 oder irgendwie 8,90 oder irgendwie.
So was.
Nee, Vmware Workstation Pro hab ich.
8,50 für ein Key.
8,90.
Ey, dass es Mittel und Wege gibt, ja, aber da posten wir hier nix im Chat jetzt.
Weil das ist ein Monk-Hard-Toss.
Wird das überhaupt noch weiterentwickelt?
Das Nordkorea-Linux.
Okay.
Chat.
Bis morgen, macht's gut.
See you.